>> Tucker: WELL, THAT CREEPY
PORN LAWYER WORKING FOR STORMY
DANIELS HAD ANOTHER BUSY
WEEKEND ON CABLE TELEVISION
WHERE HE VOWED TO INVADE MORE
PEOPLE'S PRIVATE LIVES.
FOR ME, IT'S TIME HE, HIMSELF,
WAS GIVEN A CLOSER LOOK.
HERE IS WHAT THE FEDERALIST
MOLLY HEMINGWAY SUGGESTED THE
OTHER DAY.
>> HE IS THE FRONT MAN FOR A
WELL-FUND AND A
WELL-COORDINATED OPERATION
THAT RECEIVED NEXT TO NO
CRITICISM OR REFLECTION BY
MANY PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA.
I THINK IT IS WORTH ASKING WHO
IS THIS GUY?
HOW DOES HE HAVE ACCESS TO
SPECIAL COUNSEL DOCUMENTS?
WHO IS PAYING FOR THIS?
IT'S WORTH FINDING OUT THIS
THING THAT IS DRIVING SO MUCH
OF THE COVERAGE.
>> Tucker: WHO IS THE CREEPY
PORN LAWYER?
WE DON'T ASK THE QUESTIONS
ENOUGH.
BUT MARK STEYN JOINS US.
WHO IS THIS GUY?
>> HE IS A WACKY GUY.
HE USED TO RUN TULL'S COFFEE
COMPANY.
FOR MOST OF US NORTH OF THE
BORDER SOUNDS LIKE A BACK
JOKE.
HE HAD A COMPANY, IF YOU'RE A
SUCCESSFUL LAWYER YOU'D HAVE
GLOBAL BARRISTERS BUT HE HAD
ONE THAT WAS GLOBAL BARISTAS
AND GOT SUED NOT PAYING FOR
$160,000 WORTH OF COFFEE,
WHICH IS LITERALLY GROUNDS FOR
A LAWSUIT.
I MEAN, I DON'T QUITE
UNDERSTAND.
THIS GUY, THIS GUY NOT ONLY
DOESN'T HE APPEAR TO HAVE EVER
MADE ANY MONEY FOR HIS
CLIENTS, HIS OWN LAW FIRM WENT
BANKRUPT.
I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF --
BECAUSE AMERICA EMPLOYS AS
MANY LAWYERS AS THE REST OF
THE PLANET COMBINED.
I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF A LAWYER
SO INCOMPETENT HIS OWN FIRM
GOES BANKRUPT.
THIS GUY IS A VERY ECCENTRIC
FIGURE.
AS MOLLY SAID THERE IS A LOT
MORE TO BE FOUND OUT ABOUT
HIM.
>> Tucker: WHAT DOES IT SAY
ABOUT CABLE TELEVISION OR THE
OTHER TWO NETWORKS THAT THIS
GUY HAS BEEN THE SINGLE MOST
FREQUENT GUEST MAYBE EVER?
>> WELL, I THINK WHAT IT SAYS
IS ACTUALLY THAT HE IS MUCH
BETTER AT BEING A CABLE GUEST
THAN A LAWYER.
I MEAN THE TRAGEDY HERE --
>> Tucker: GOOD POINT.
>> -- IS THAT STORMY -- I BET
YOU, POOR OLD STORMY WON'T SEE
$70 -- SHE WON'T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO BUY A DECAF AVENATTI
AT THE TULLY'S COFFEE STORE BY
THE TIME IT'S ALL THROUGH.
BUT HE WILL GET PUBLICITY OUT
OF IT.
THAT IS IT.
>> Tucker: THAT IS A REALLY
GOOD POINT.